Speaker 1: Let's go next to Brian
from Ireland. Brian, welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, how are you? Yeah,
I'm doing well. Yeah, yeah, I'm
doing well. Thanks very much.
Just a couple of small questions today.
When Trump tees that announcement and,
you know, it turned out to just be those trading
cards, I don't know. I was I was. But, you know,
the whole thing has been ridiculous
for the last number of years. But, yes,
I didn't think it would go to this stage.
Speaker 1: So that was a new low
in your mind? The digital trading.
Speaker 2: Cards. I just I don't know in any of
my wildest dreams, I didn't think that's what the
announcement was going to be. I didn't know. Yeah,
but I just want, like, what do you think here?
What what do you think could be the next bottom
of the barrel that we find? Like, what could be
the next? Just, you know, just a wireless possible
imagination thing in the world. TRUMP What?
Speaker 1: What honestly, I don't know. Is
it is it Trump? Trump? Is it Trump doing some
kind of celebrity boxing match? I honestly I
have no clue. I have no idea because every
time there's a new low and we say it can't
possibly get any worse than this, then there's
another new low. Is it Trump doing infomercials
for some kind of rotisserie cooking device
like Ron Popeil? You know, whatever it was
called? I genuinely don't know. Brian, you
could tell me anything. And I would say it's
possible that that will be the next thing.
Speaker 2: It's a it's increasingly funny
to imagine, you know, if he'd go into a coma
back in 2014 or whatever, everyone was waking
up now just, oh, where do I start explaining?
Speaker 1: It would be completely unbelievable.
No, you're absolutely right. And part of that, I
think, is there's an important lesson in there,
which is even all of us in 2017, in January
2017, when Trump was inaugurated, I think if
we had been told, here's what it will be like
in 2022, most of us would not have believed it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, 100%.
Speaker 1: And now it is what it is,
you know. In Ireland, are people just making
fun of Trump? Like, is he a laughing stock?
Speaker 2: I certainly was for a
long time. I think, you know, since
he left office and I guess left Twitter, etc.,
he's been. Talks about a bit less. But you know I
follow he has colleagues across from most people's
I'm still interested but yeah I think like most my
family wouldn't know much these days. But what is.
Speaker 1: Interesting,
it's probably for the best, to be honest.
Speaker 2: Probably just one quick thing
on a on the World Cup, briefly, while we can still
talk about that. Sure. When I would do it quickly.
But what did you make of the Argentina
goalkeeper's kind of mind games in the penalty
shootout? Do you think that was an effective
strategy that came into play? Or is it being.
Speaker 1: When you say mind games,
what specifically are you referring to?
Speaker 2: Well, there was a
cameraman which had a French
taker's. It was whether it was their the first
one that missed or not. But the the goalkeeper,
Martinez had the ball in his hand and it looked
like he was going to give it to the French guy,
but then actually threw it away and made him
walk after it, you know, things like that.
Speaker 1: Oh, I didn't notice that. That's
interesting. I mean, listen, it's pretty
funny. My my view on all this stuff. It's sort of
like this controversy about chess, grandmaster and
friend of the show, Hikaru Nakamura, stalling
in order to take advantage of a rule related
to how the match clock relates to the game clock.
It's sort of like if it's not against the rules,
you figure out what to do to win. And I don't know
if throwing the ball, I, I just, I don't have much
of a feeling on it one way or the other, you know.
Speaker 2: Yeah. No, fair enough. Yeah,
I know. I'm not certainly not accusing
them of breaking rules or anything. I
just thought it was interesting that he was
getting into the French player's head and
it seemed to work to a degree. So.
Speaker 1: Hey, listen, real quick,
a friend of mine when he was in Ireland went
on a potato walking food tour where it sounds
like a joke. But he would stop at they would
stop at different places with a local guide,
each place preparing potatoes in
dramatically different ways. Is
is that a complete tourist trap or is
that actually something like locally
interesting culinary in Ireland?
Speaker 2: Well, I haven't heard
of that specific attraction, but to be perfectly
honest with you, even though it is a stereotype,
I would still go on that tour. Little sound.
Speaker 1: I love potatoes. I mean,
it sounds pretty good to me. I have to say.
Speaker 2: If you're if you're a wedding here in
Ireland, I'll finish up with this. But if you're
a guest at a wedding and it's kind of food being
served, family style, you know, dishes, etc.,
yeah, there'll be there'll be three different
types of potato at least, you know, there'll
be mashed there being Dauphine or whatever.
You know there's going to be a few different.
Speaker 1: Thing was I like that. That's it.
All right. Well, I got to get over there and
try some of these potatoes, I have to tell you.
Speaker 2: Please do. All
right. Good to talk to you.
Speaker 1: All right, Brian from Ireland,
thank you so much for the call very much.
Appreciate it. Let's go to Jill from
Burbank, California. Jill, welcome to
the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: Okay. I love Big
Fan and just have many questions. I have written
them down, but I'm just going to do two of them.
I don't know. Whenever we watch one of those Trump
Trump rallies. At the end, he says, This country
doesn't belong to them. This country belongs
to you. Yes. Isn't that a fascist? Like that's
the biggest dagger in like America's throat,
saying this country basically belongs to you
guys. Only what America is is all about, you know,
everybody else. And we love our neighbors, like.
Speaker 1: Well, if you.
Speaker 2: If you.
Speaker 1: Question them about it, they would
say, what Trump means is this is the country
of the people, not not literally just the people
at the Trump rally. It's just the country of the
people is what they say is meant by it.
Speaker 2: Well, to me how it sounds.
It's those people and not the other people.
Speaker 1: Totally fair. I'm just telling you,
like, if you confronted them with
it, this is what they would say.
Speaker 2: I mean, they say a lot of
a lot of things that are happening,
basically that made them hypocrites. Yes.
Like the one I saw from yesterday. The lady
was driving a SUV with an hash tag f J.B. in the
back. Yep. But she had all the Christmas stuff
around it. Christmas stands for, like,
love, you know, and everything, like,
from, you know, sharing and caring and all.
Like, that's what Christmas is. And she I mean,
how can you be an evangelical or a true Christian
and also put in, you know, f j being in the
back of the car, that really blew my mind.
Speaker 1: I'm with you. The hypocrisy is is
quite stunning, but it is prevalent. And it is
it's like it's own virus in the United States.
Speaker 2: Right. Can I can I do one more
question? This this is going to be actually a
question. All right. Those were just statements.
Speaker 1: It's better when people just get
right to questions going forward. But
I'll allow it's got to be real quick,
though. I got a lot of people holding.
Speaker 2: Okay. So if you remember Trump
said oranges of the investigation and he
said it like many, many times, and then he
explained it as origin, like the beginning
of the beginnings. So that was from many,
many, many, many examples. The other one was
during the rally, he said, Oh, Mark Zuckerberg
last week came to the White House and he was
out of the loop. You know, yeah. It was like.
Speaker 1: Years after he
left the Oval Office. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Right. So is he done in
your in your in your head? Is is he
done done from a mental standpoint?
Speaker 1: Listen, I don't know. I
don't know. Because on the one hand, Trump does
remember things and can sometimes be coherent,
but he just like glitches so much. And I really
don't know what's going on with Trump cognitively.
I'm not sure. I'm not really in a position
to say it's very strange. And that's what
our position has been, is bizarre and is he just
loses his train of thought and that everything.
But ultimately, I don't know what's going
on. Question Probably more for a neurologist.
Speaker 2: Right? Okay. Maybe we should
have a neurologist on your show to go over.
Speaker 1: Jill I will look
into it. I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Speaker 1: All right. Let's.
A lot going on there. A lot, lot, lot
going on there. Let's go. Actually,
you know what? Let's let's take a
very quick break. If you're holding,
don't hang up because we're going back to the
phones, but we're going to take a very brief
break, reset, let emotions simmer, and then
we'll hear from some more people in a moment